I want to play this for you this is a
news report local news report out of the
Communist nation of
California uh which is on the way to
Banning tackle football for
children and
uh I have plenty to say about it but
first let's play the news report here's
the local ABC
affiliate for kids under the age of 12
tackle football could soon be a relic of
the past in California it's all thanks
to a new bill authored by Sacramento
assembly member Kevin mccardy that's
making its way through the state
legislature when we look at kids under
the age of 12 tackle football is a
high-risk sport Dr Brian fely is the
head of sports medicine at UCSF he says
he supports the bill because of the
elevated risk of concussions that comes
with tackle football fely says these
risks are especially heightened for
young kids whose brains are in their
most important stages of development
you're at higher risk for anxiety
depression suicidal ideation phy says
instead of tackle football flag football
is a far safer option not everyone
agrees with this bill though that
includes some local coaches here in
Oakland who tell me they fear that it
will disproportionately impact young
kids of color we do a lot of low-income
families a lot of uh families that go
through struggles maybe not have a male
figure at home chewy Ora and Damon
Gardner are the coaches of Youth Taco
football team the Oakland dynamites they
tell me for teams like theirs football
is more than just a sport it's a way to
teach kids about things like friendship
leadership and camaraderie they also say
sports besides football also carry the
risk of injuries you can jump in
basketball you can fall down hit your
head got concussion look at the picture
you playing baseball they throwing 90 M
hour at you and as for flag football
coaches chewy and Damon say they don't
think it's a suitable alternative flag
football just doesn't carry enough kids
we have 30 kids flag football typically
don't about have have maybe have about
15 okay so so uh maybe it won't surprise
you to learn that I hate this idea
Banning tackle football and it's
something that you hear now California
obviously is first up to the to the
plate
um
but it it's there's support for it all
across the country and my my prediction
is if if uh if California does it then
uh a bunch of other states will follow
and I think it's terrible and and this
probably will surprise you I actually
agree with the claim that those coach
has made that this will
disproportionately impact minorities so
this is this is the one time where I
think that argument holds water and it's
and not only holds water but it's an
important argument it's not the most
important argument it's not the first
argument to be made but there is truth
to it so we'll get to that in a moment
but
generally um you know this is a
reflection of our feminized society yet
again
it is a very
feminine womanly thing to look at a
sport where boys are tackling each other
and say oh that's too dangerous that
they're going to hurt themselves we need
to get rid of that now I understand why
women feel that way like I don't hold it
against women for feeling my wife feels
that way about tackle football for for
kids at that age and and that's okay
she's a woman I like I get
it um but that's also why women are not
the foremost authorities on what sorts
of activities are best for boys any more
than men are authorities on what sort of
activities are best for girls so when
you're trying to decide if a certain
activity is good or appropriate for a
boy a woman should not be the first
person that you ask now except the
problem is and I know you'll point out
well the guy that that authored this
bill is a guy it wasn't even a woman
true because we live in this feminized
Society especially in California so even
the men have the mentality of women
I know there are plenty of men who
support this I talked about on Twitter
today there's plenty of men coming out
well yeah it's too dangerous it's too
dangerous for the kids we can't do that
um so and if that's your mentality like
you you have the mentality of a woman
you're looking at this like a
woman um saying well why can't they just
play flag football instead well because
flag football is lame okay that's why
because girls can play you know
why you know why we don't have boys play
flag football we let them cuz can play
flag
football if you change it to flag
football you're going to lose half of
your participants like the coach has
said and half of the ones that you end
up with Will Be Girls and it's not a
coincidence that you know they were
showing the footage of the b-roll of
kids playing tackle football was all
boys and then they switched over to show
a b-roll of flag football it was a bunch
of girls right so football will go from
being a masculine sport for
boys who who want to go out there and
tackle and and be rough
to a fun activity for girls and boys to
do together which is to say it will lose
all of its
value and I'm not saying that there's no
value in activities for girls and boys
to do together what I'm saying is that
football isn't meant to be that sort of
activity and and generally organized
Sports in general are not supposed to be
that sort of activity if you're looking
to save money this year but don't want
to sacrifice the quality of life you're
used to Pure Talk has your back instead
of paying your current cell phone
provider $60 $70 or $80 a line Pure Talk
has unlimited plans starting at just 20
bucks a month you'll get the same
phenomenal coverage that you're used to
on America's Most Dependable 5G Network
for just 20 bucks a month this is how
the average family saves almost $1,000 a
year it's time to switch to a wireless
company that shares your values a
company that isn't afraid to invest in
shows like mine a company that is
veteran owned and serves veterans so
what are you waiting for switch to Pure
Talk in as little as 10 minutes and
start saving today their Us customer
service team is waiting to serve you go
to Pur talk uh.com Walsh and right now
you'll save an additional 50% off your
first month that's Pur talk.com Walsh to
get connected now again Pur talk.com
Walsh to start off the year saving on
wireless with a company that you can be
proud of so here are a few facts um
first of all tackle football for kids is
not that dangerous uh there is this very
uh again very womanly panic over tackle
football it's too dangerous they're
hitting each
other it's not that bad actually
especially for young kids in fact for
kids in that age range like the exact
age range that they are Banning it for
or going to ban it for it it is is
especially safe at that age range in
fact football is safer than other sports
like baseball did you know that did you
know that more kids die from baseball
injuries every year than from football
injuries under the age of
12 which in a way is kind of easy to do
because like no kids die at under the
age of 12 from football injuries but it
does happen in
baseball um why is that well because at
the age of 8 n 10 kids are not strong
enough they're not fast enough they're
not powerful enough to seriously damage
each other from running into each other
you know you don't see like for the most
part these big NFL Style hits happening
at the between niney olds on the
football field now on the other hand a
line drive to the
face can kill you at any age and it does
kill
kids so so I mean that really should be
the end of the conversation it really
should
be baseball is more likely to kill a
10-year-old than football just a fact it
is and I'm not advocating that we ban
baseball not at all I'm only trying to
make the point
here and also by the way because these
people are morons they don't understand
that that the worst thing you could do
is Ban tackle football for a young ages
but it's still legal for the because now
you're taking kids and they're not going
to
learn you know when they're still when
they're still young and they're not very
fast and strong they're not going to
learn how to tackle and then you bring
them into high school and now they're
bigger and much stronger and
faster and they've never learned how to
tackle and now you're saying all right
kids go
crazy now you're getting up with lot
more injuries because of
that and but second the second point
which I think is the broader Point
that's important is that is that as I've
argued many times Society needs to have
outlets for for male aggression and
energy okay Society must have outlets
for that and yes the outlets are going
to be
violent and and if you have a feminine
mentality you will look at that and say
Well that's just that's not good it's
violent but what you have to understand
is that it's you don't have a choice
okay that's what I'm trying to tell you
boys are aggressive they have a lot of
energy they they are violent okay that's
just how boys are that's
natural and so as a society you are
going to experience that one way or
another it is going to come out one way
or
another so do we harness it do we use it
do we direct it towards a goal which is
what sports are all
about it's also what about a lot of
these playground activities that most of
them have been banned too you know of
course they don't play dodgeball or
anything like that in schools but that's
what that's about too it's like what's
dodgeball it's just take a ball and
fling it at your friend as hard as you
can and try to hit him that's the whole
fun of
dodgeball um and we take all that away
you know my boys uh 10 and seven they
tackle each other all the time they do
it without pads okay without like the
training um they they do it in a context
that's probably potentially more
dangerous do I tell them to stop doing
that I mean yeah sometimes if it's if
it's an inappropriate context I don't
let them just run Rowdy whenever they
want but but generally I don't have a
rule that says you can never rough house
I don't have that rule of course I don't
have that rule because they're boys and
this is an important part of being a boy
it's not an important part of being a
girl okay girls don't do this
and I know I'm going to hear from like
the one parent out of a seven million
who says oh my girl's very sh no
nine-year-old girls are not getting
together and recreationally beating the
crap out of each other that's what
nine-year-old boys
do and they have that energy they have
that propensity for
violence and football is one way of
harnessing it tackle football especially
specifically that's maybe its greatest
value especially for kids and yet one by
one as a society we're we are taking
away all of the healthy organized
outlets for male aggression how is that
working out how's it working
out like are we ending up with less
violence and less aggression in society
no we're
not we're just ending up with a lot more
of it um that you know we're ring about
the kind of violence that that doesn't
happen on the DodgeBall field or
football
field and that brings us to the the
point those coaches were making about
the disparate impact and the one time
I'll agree with that point because as
they said young black boys especially
need these kinds of outlets and why do
they need it well because many of them
don't have fathers at home and uh you
know uh fathers if you have a father at
home who's active and involved then one
of the thing a father does is is is to
help a boy understand how to take all
that energy and channel it in healthy
ways uh if you don't have a father then
you don't have that and that's why in
particular those kinds of boys tackle
football is very very good for them even
if it even with the dangers and the
risks it's still very good on top of
that there's the male role models the
male influences that they get from their
coaches I mean from a lot for a lot of
these boys uh their coach is the only
father figure they're ever going to
have and so we should not be doing a
single thing to try to take that away we
should be encouraging a lot more of it
you go to a place like Oakland the more
of those kids you can get into sports
the better every single one of those
kids is playing sports fantastic
you know you should be you should be
open you should be creating more
football leagues not taking them
away um and football is is a just you
know there are other sports of course
there's that that are you know perfectly
great healthy outlets for that kind of
male energy baseball's one of them
basketball but football is is just
different and if you don't watch
football if you haven't played it you
might not really understand this but
it's got it just it's has a different it
has a like kind of militaristic feel to
it you know the football players talk
about going out and going to war and and
uh I mean they're not literally going to
war of course but it has that it just
has that kind of feel to it and that's
one of the things that draws young men
to it and it's why it can be an
incredibly important um outlet and
influence for young men and uh and but
you know so we got to take it
away the worst thing we do the young men
are not allowed to have anything they
just can't have
anything because we look at everything
from this from this
pathetic weak feminized mentality and
and we said that's that's
upsetting this a little too rough calm
down kids here take some drugs we get
we'll drug you instead to calm you down
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there